I think you're a
moth quiet harmless drawn to shiny
things what have you doing I just
thought that maybe I could help you're
not leaving us you're not leaving
so I mean this isn't the kind of movie
that I think lends itself to a 20 second
elevator pitch so I'm AAG Imaging there
she wasn't she didn't you know you
probably were just waiting for a script
was that when you really got an idea of
the scope of the project or was she you
know giving you ideas along the way
promise you on wom we got more idea of
what it was because she pitched us kind
of the cold open this one it was more
hey I've written the script read it and
then see what you think um and that's
the great thing about Emerald she's
always she always goes away and writes
it you know she's willing to kind of do
that work so I think she wants people
who love the movie as much as she does
and she wants Partners who feel the same
way um to be as invested as she is the
score much like the movie is is all
encompassing it's dark and funny and
Lush and Gothic in places um were there
other places that you drew inspiration
from you know the first challenge was to
create the world of saltburn that's the
thing that Oliver is trying to Fed into
and trying to Aspire to um and one of
the first things the first ideas Emerald
had for that was um she said Anthony I
love organ
um there's not enough scores with organ
it's and it's such a it's such a
versatile instrument because it's so
human um it can be very Soulful and sad
which was really great for Oliver when
he was kind of on his own and didn't
have any friends and then it can be very
kind of or inspiring and Gothic and and
intimidating which was really great for
the approach to the house the final
thing that we we experienced with the
organ was to subvert it into a lustful
throb which runs throughout a lot of the
score and emerald she loved the idea of
that it's such a like throbbing pulses
are such a prevalent thing in in NAU's
dance music obviously as seen in the
party so she was very much kind of
looking for something in the score that
was a subversion of that and we like
this idea that you know when everyone's
distracted downstairs still partying you
know when you skullking around upstairs
um in Oliver's case trying to you know
um Peak into Felix's bath
bathroom the idea that there's a kind of
afterglow of something that's kind of
creeping through the floorboards I think
she really liked that and so we we know
we tried it with some just Sy but I said
why don't we do it with an organ that it
will kind of keep that um that sort of
um Universal Character throughout the
score and um and she loved it and it was
it was really fun to wow to use I want
to go back to the amazing cast I want
your character eleth is she's so
fascinating because she can say the most
awful
things but we kind of love her um what
was sort of your initial take on her Did
you sort of instantly know who this
woman
was I think I did having sort of spent
most of my life in England um I'm afraid
there are quite a few elets around the
UK people who've sort of chilled me with
their sort of faint praise and you know
the things that you know somebody says
something you hear it and you know that
the words are complimentary but you know
that in the delivery it's definitely not
a
compliment you know when somebody says
oh how clever and you know that you've
done something wrong or it's not
pleasing and you don't know what it is
and it's it's maddening and makes you
feel very insecure and eleth was really
my chance to get back at all the people
who'd never made me feel
insecure um you know she's the person
who sort of says oh how punctual yeah
and you just know that it's wrong and
you think well why is it wrong it's a
good thing isn't it to be isn't it to be
punctual no it has you have to be 5
minutes late you know whatever it is um
so yeah she was a she was a delight to
me but it's a defense mechanism you know
we have to have empathy for her because
it's a massive defense mechanism it's a
way that you know the British upper
classes avoid talking about anything
serious or meaningful or emotional
you're very good at making us care and
even root for characters that maybe we
shouldn't you know thinking about I care
a lot and Gone Girl like on paper these
aren't necessarily nice people but you
you never treat them as cardboard
villains they're always very complex
layered characters I think it's
important when you play someone nasty
that they're still fun to watch I
remember when I was making I care a lot
I was living in the same city as the
Director and we would go I would go
around to his flat and we would watch
lots of films and work out when you know
what was it that made a a bad character
or an unlikable character fun to watch
you know I think you want them to be
entertaining mhm and I think eleth is
very entertaining but I don't think
that's to do with me I think that's you
know Emerald has written this very
entertaining family um they just are I
mean it's a very entertaining
film as well as sort of shocking and
appalling and you know it's she's
written a film about desire about about
all the things that we want and you know
sex runs through the whole film in the
most you know dangerous and erotic
way um and all our characters have a
different relationship to it I think
eleth herself is terrified of sex I
think she's a sort of quite a bloodless
creature really um maybe that came into
your writing
I to the scoring does she have her own
theme like each character there is a
there is um a really important moment in
the in the score um and actually I think
of everyone who's told me about the
score it's their favorite moment and
Rosman had done this absolutely blood
curdling scream um when she finds her
son in in the middle of the Maze and I
was working on the Queue and I was like
this is going to you know once you've
heard that I have to find a way to fra
there has to be fracture because you
there's no way I can carry on the way I
did and um and then uh and and then
hearing it in the Final Mix I mean like
it really inspired the music very much
um you know as did I'm so lucky I get to
come into this with everyone's craft
everyone's performances kind of sort of
screaming at you because it's so good
and you better not it
up and I want to talk some more about
this amazing cast and and starting with
obviously Barry kogen sounds like
Emerald really gives her cast ownership
of their roles and they're allowed to
improvise I just spoke to him recently
and he told me like some of the things
he does at the grave scene that was an
improv on the day was he someone who was
always sort of surprising you you know
Emerald's so good at distilling her
vision to people and having people
understand the journey that she wants to
go on that I think everyone is so
invested in the movie when they start
that they feel comfortable enough that
they can try things they can push the
boundaries or if Emerald asks you to do
something you know it's coming from the
right place and it's coming from a place
that is advancing the story or you know
real for the character so I think it
just makes those conversations so much
easier um and I think Barry is such a
powerful performer because I think it's
as much about what he doesn't say as it
is about what he does
um so you know you can just leave the
camera on him and you know you get
something magic but I think it was that
element where I think there was just an
incredible trust between everyone I
think like Rosman said there was this
kind of familiar environment where you
know everyone felt like a family which
meant people were willing to kind of go
the extra mile together and it meant we
could I think as we were shooting it in
the house particularly and trying to do
it as chronologically as possible it
meant that we could react uh in the
moment so say scenes were feeling like
they were more tense than other scenes
Emerald would you know add things take
things away or realize I might need to
add something there because the tension
isn't quite there so yeah I think it all
kind of stemed from her being able to
really kind of get across her vision to
people from a very very early stage have
you been surprised by how much people um
root for
Oliver I don't think so I think again I
felt this when I first read the script
You know despite some of the things that
happened in it there's certain things
that feel very relatable you know I
think a lot of people when they first
really oh I'm Oliver you know people can
really relate to his journey or his
wants um obviously certainer not
everyone goes as far as he goes but um
yeah I I I wasn't I'm not that surprised
that people kind of root for him and I
think it's the power of that ending
where you feel complicit in you know
feel complicit in his happiness and and
that kind of and that was something we
shifted as well where it wasn't
originally a dance it was a walk through
the house and I I think again and was
like it just doesn't feel right it feels
like there should be that Triumph at the
end and again Barry was like yeah you're
right it feels feels like that's what it
should be CU I think we wanted the
audience to go out with that feeling of
of yeah of Triumph and sharing in his
glory I I think we want to identify with
Oliver because if we were in elth we
wouldn't know it you know I don't think
she she she's probably not the most
self-aware person um but that's probably
what makes her so much fun to
play no she's she's very she's very
clueless I mean she has a she has an
idea of herself as a very you know Wise
and benevolent Soul who's seen it all
and you know very very caring but
actually she misses
loads um you know she and she's just
Longing To Be absolved she sort of she's
sort of got a hunch that
she's you know she she longs to be
patient but actually she's impatient she
wants to be she gets bored easily she
but you know she she loves the idea of
a sort of pity party you know she wants
somebody to come in who's less fortunate
that she can bestow kindness on because
that makes her feel good about herself
um and I think she is remains clueless
to the end about Oliver's real character
yeah I think she sort of understood him
in the first breath as Felix's new
friend and I don't think she really
wavers from that um even when she sees
him in the coffee shop it's somehow
somebody connected to the Past somebody
connected to saltburn when it still held
its magic you know saltburn to her is
almost it's her whole
world you know when she says you're not
leaving us you're not leaving saltburn
it's it's I think in that sentence it's
if you do the salt saltburn will fall
apart I will fall apart I am saltburn I
will fall apart and so when she sees him
in the coffee shop it's this tug on the
strings to get him to come back and and
sort of revivify the the house again
yeah um it's tragic really no it it
really is um it's also very very fun to
watch um and I want to remind everyone
it will actually be on Amazon Prime
starting December 22nd so you can watch
it again and again thank you so much for
being a great audience and thank you for
being here thank
[Applause]
you